It's been 50 years since the U.S. Surgeon General's report on smoking and health spurred one of the largest public health behavior change success stories of the 20th century. Before and since this groundbreaking report's release, psychology has been at the forefront of smoking cessation efforts. Research into the biological and behavioral mechanisms of addiction has led to many successful treatments for nicotine addicts. In this episode, we talk with Dr. Sherry McKee, a researcher whose work has focused on gender, gender differences in smoking. She discusses why women have a harder time kicking the habit and what science can do to help them quit. Sherry McKee has been working on finding out why women have a harder time quitting smoking than men. Her work focuses on the role stress and depression play in smoking behaviors for both men and women. She is director of the Yale
自美国外科医生关于吸烟与健康的报告发表以来，已经过去了50年，该报告促成了20世纪公共卫生行为改变方面最成功的案例之一。在这份具有里程碑意义的报告发布之前和之后，心理学一直处于戒烟努力的最前沿。对成瘾的生物学和行为机制的研究已经为尼古丁成瘾者带来了许多成功的治疗方法。在本期节目中，我们采访了谢里·麦基博士，她是一位专注于性别以及吸烟中的性别差异的研究人员。她讨论了为什么女性更难戒掉烟瘾以及科学能做些什么来帮助她们戒烟。谢里·麦基一直致力于找出为什么女性比男性更难戒烟。她的工作重点是压力和抑郁在男性和女性吸烟行为中所起的作用。她是耶鲁大学的主任
Behavioral Pharmacology Laboratory. She's also an associate professor of psychiatry at the Yale School of Medicine. Her smoking research has been funded by the Office of research on women's health and the National Institute of Drug Abuse. Thank you for joining us, Dr. McKee. Thank you for having me. Is there a critical health disparity among female smokers? And if so, what is being done to address that? There are critical health disparities among women's smokers. Smoking is still the leading cause of preventable morbidity or mortality in the U.S. Obesity is second, alcohol use is third. We know that across industrialized nations, women's smokers are going to be responsible for a half-meatible.
行为药理学实验室。她还是耶鲁大学医学院的精神病学副教授。她的吸烟研究得到了女性健康研究办公室和国家药物滥用研究所的资助。谢谢你加入我们，麦基博士。谢谢邀请我。女性吸烟者之间是否存在严重的健康差距？如果是这样，正在采取什么措施来解决这个问题？女性吸烟者之间存在严重的健康差距。吸烟仍然是美国可预防的发病率或死亡率的主要原因。肥胖居第二位，酒精使用居第三位。我们知道，在工业化国家中，女性吸烟者将导致每年半百万人的死亡，并且这一数字预计在未来25年内将呈指数级增长。现在，关于她们的健康影响，当你在男女之间等同烟草暴露时，女性对严重的烟草相关疾病更敏感，这包括肺癌和心脏病等。女性还会经历性别特异性的健康风险，主要与其生殖健康有关。因此，她们有月经周期方面的问题，她们更早进入更年期。当然，在怀孕期间吸烟的女性会有一系列与怀孕相关的消极或不良事件，比如子痫前期以及低体重儿。因此，除了女性经历更多与吸烟相关的健康影响外，女性也较少
million deaths per year, and this rate is expected to exponentially increase over the next 25 years. Now, with regards to their health effects, when you equate tobacco exposure between men and women, women are more susceptible to serious tobacco-related disease, and this includes things like lung cancer and heart disease. Women also experience sex-specific health risks, primarily related to their reproductive health. So they have problems with their menstrual cycle, they enter menopause earlier. And of course, women who smoke during pregnancy have a whole host of pregnancy related negative or adverse events, things like preeclampsia and then lower birth weight babies. So in addition to women experiencing more health-related effects of smoking, women are also less
能够戒烟。过去40年一直在收集国家数据，在过去的40年里的每一年，女性的戒烟率都低于男性的戒烟率。现在，使这个问题更加复杂的是，目前可用的药物对女性吸烟者而言效果不佳或通常效果不佳。在某种程度上，所有这些由美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）批准的药物，都针对大脑中的烟碱受体，这可能不是针对女性的最佳策略。因此，得知女性比男性戒烟更困难这很有趣，你知道的，考虑到美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）曾说过女性往往比男性更有健康意识。你知道的，你会认为戒烟可能会更容易。但你能告诉我们你所了解到的为什么情况并非如此吗？嗯，已经确定了许多因素，被认为构成了女性戒烟更困难的原因。这些因素包括与月经周期相关的因素，也为了管理体重而吸烟，以及为了调节不良情绪和压力而吸烟。你的部分工作重点是为试图戒烟的女性量身定制治疗方案。
able to quit smoking. There's been national data that's being collected over the last 40 years, and every single year, for the last 40 years, quit rates for women are lower than quit rates for men. Now, compounding this problem, currently available medications are not as effective or generally not as effective for women's smokers. To some extent, all of these medications, which are approved by the FDA, all target the nicotinic receptor in the brain, and this might not be the optimal strategy for women. So it's interesting to learn that women have more difficulty quitting smoking than men, you know, given that the CDC has said women tend to be more health conscious than men. You know, you would think that quitting smoking would maybe easier. But can you tell us what you've learned about why this is not the case? Well, there have been a number of factors identified that are thought to underlie why women have more difficulty quitting smoking. These include things like factors related to their menstrual cycle, also smoking to manage their weight. and smoking to regulate their negative mood and stress. Part of your work focuses on tailoring treatments for women who are trying to quit.
你为什么认为针对特定性别的治疗会有效？你能提供一个例子吗？当然。为了制定对女性吸烟者有效的治疗方法，我们需要针对构成她们吸烟行为基础的因素。现在，这有点概括化，但通过多项研究，我们知道女性通常比男性更多地吸烟以调节负面情绪和压力。这并不是说男性在感到压力时不抽烟，但这对于女性来说比对男性更真实。
Why do you think gender-specific treatments can work? And could you provide an example? Sure. To develop effective treatments for women smokers, we need to target factors which underlie their smoking behavior. Now, this is a bit of a generalization, but across a number of studies, we know that women generally smoke to regulate negative mood and stress more so than men. That's not to say that men don't smoke when they're stressed, but this is more true for women than it is for men.
当你观察男性时，他们往往更多地为了从尼古丁中获得的强化作用而吸烟。同样，这并不是说女性也从尼古丁中获得强化作用，但这不像对男性那样是一个强烈的促使她们吸烟的因素。因此，我们目前正在瞄准大脑中所谓的去甲肾上腺素系统，以了解这是否是开发治疗吸烟者药物的一个重要焦点。从动物研究中，我们知道该系统参与了应激反应，它也参与了来自尼古丁的强化作用。
And when you look at men, they tend to smoke more for the reinforcement that they receive from nicotine. And again, this is not to say that women don't also receive reinforcement for nicotine, but it's not as strong as a factor that motivates their smoking as it is for men. So we are currently targeting what's called the norgenergic system in the brain, to understand if this is an important focus for developing medications to treat smokers. From animal studies, we know that this system is involved in stress responses, and it's also involved in the reinforcement from nicotine.
我们认为针对该系统的药物可能对女性和男性都有效，但可能通过不同的机制起作用。我们的初步研究表明确实如此。我们研究了一种名为胍法辛的药物，它最初是作为降压药开发的。在吸烟者中，我们已经证明它减少了男性和女性的吸烟量，但它往往更能减少压力以及压力对女性吸烟行为的负面影响，而且它也往往更能减少男性与尼古丁相关的强化作用。我们对这项研究改善女性和男性戒烟率的潜力感到兴奋。所以你谈了很多关于
We feel that medications targeting this system may be effective for both women and men, but might operate through different mechanisms. And our initial studies have shown this to be the case. We've studied a medication called Guamphosine, which was originally developed as a blood pressure medication. In smokers, we have shown that it decreases smoking in men and women, but that it tends to reduce the effect of stress and the negative effect that stress has on smoking behavior more so for women, and then it also tends to reduce nicotine-related reinforcement more so for men. We are excited by the potential of this research to improve quit rates for both women and men. So you're talking a lot about how
压力与吸烟的关系。关于压力如何影响吸烟者及其戒烟能力，我们了解多少？压力是人们继续吸烟的主要原因，同时也是人们重新开始吸烟的主要原因。大多数吸烟者都想戒烟。如果你问一个吸烟者，你知道的，他们是否想戒烟，他们会说是的。然后你问他们关于他们目前戒烟的计划，他们会说，嗯，现在不是好时候。我在工作中有个很大的截止日期。我的孩子们真的让我压力很大。他们会找出阻止他们进行戒烟尝试的障碍，而且很多时候这些障碍都与压力有关。我们知道压力对女性吸烟的影响比对男性更大。我们进行了一些实验室研究，我们把男女带进实验室，让他们感到有压力，
stress relates to smoking. What do we know about how stress impacts smokers and their ability to quit? Stress is a primary reason why people continue to smoke, and also it's a primary reason why people relapse back to smoking. Most smokers want to quit smoking. If you ask a smoker, you know, if they want to quit, they'll say yes. And then you ask them about their current plans to quit and they'll say, well, now's not a good time. I have a big deadline at work. My kids are really stressing me out. They'll identify some barriers that prevent them from engaging in a quit attempt and very often they're stress-related. We know that stress has a larger effect on women smoking than men. We've conducted a number of laboratory studies where we bring men and women into the lab, we stress them out,
我们发现女性比男性更快地去拿香烟，而且当她们感到压力时，她们抽得更剧烈。所以她们吸得更深，她们从一支烟中抽的口数也更多。那么抑郁和吸烟呢？抑郁症患者中吸烟的普遍程度如何，正在采取什么措施来帮助对香烟上瘾的临床抑郁症患者？现在在美国，大约有8%的人符合重度抑郁症的标准，其中大约40%的人吸烟。所以这是一个巨大的数字。这相当于美国成年人吸烟率的两倍，后者目前约为20%。我们知道患有抑郁症的个人戒烟更困难，然而对于如何最好地帮助他们戒烟却知之甚少。
and we find that women reach for cigarettes much more quickly than men, and they smoke them much more intensely when they're stressed. So they inhale more deeply, and they also take more puffs from a cigarette. What about depression and smoking? How prevalent is smoking among people with depression and what's being done to help clinically depressed people who are addicted to cigarettes? Right now in the U.S., about 8% meet criteria for major depression, and about 40% of these people smoke. So it's a huge number. This is double the rate of smoking among U.S. adults, which is currently at about 20%. We know that individuals with depression have more difficulty quitting, yet very little is known about how best to help them stop smoking.
我们对已经进行的研究进行了审查，我们发现被研究的大多数吸烟者都有终生抑郁症诊断，相比之下，即他们在过去的某个时候患有抑郁症，而不是目前正在抑郁。因此，那些目前正在抑郁的人并不是研究的巨大焦点。此外，大多数研究甚至在研究抑郁吸烟者时也会排除目前正在服用药物或抗抑郁药来帮助治疗抑郁症的人。我们知道抑郁症似乎对女性及其在几项研究中的戒烟能力产生了更大的负面影响，然而研究或大多数研究并没有
We've conducted a review of the research that's been conducted, and we found that most smokers that are studied have lifetime diagnosis of depression versus, so they had depression at some point in their past versus being currently depressed. So those that are currently depressed have not been a huge focus of the research. Additionally, most studies will exclude, even if they're studying depressed smokers, they'll exclude people who are currently taking a medication or an antidepressant to help treat their depression. We know that depression seems to have a greater negative impact on women and their ability to quit smoking across a few of these studies, yet the studies or the majority of studies do not
专注于比较男性和女性。有一些研究表明，增加一个帮助人们管理情绪状态的成分可以是有效的，并且可以。可以帮助提高人们能够戒烟的比率。但我们知道，患有抑郁症的吸烟者有更严重的烟草戒断症状，经历更多的渴望，这些因素可能是未来治疗开发的靶点。谈到尼古丁，你提到了压力和抑郁，你知道的，尼古丁显然起到了作用。它让人上瘾。
focus on comparing men and women. There are some studies which suggest that adding a component to help people manage their mood states can be effective and can. can help improve rates of people being able to quit. But we know that smokers with depression have more severe tobacco withdrawal symptoms, experience more craving, and these factors could be targets of future treatment development. Talking about nicotine, and you mentioned stress and depression, you know, obviously nicotine plays a role. It's addictive.
我们都知道这一点。有些人呼吁烟草公司降低香烟中的尼古丁水平。你认为这在帮助人们戒烟方面会有效吗，还是说吸烟中还有更多需要解决的行为成分来帮助人们戒烟？这是一个非常有趣的问题。FDA资助了研究，检查低尼古丁香烟对吸烟行为和毒素暴露的影响。我们知道，女性吸烟较少受到尼古丁的动机驱动，更多受到所谓的
We know that. Some people have called for tobacco companies to lower nicotine levels in cigarettes. Do you think this could work in helping people stop smoking, or is there more of a behavioral component to smoking that will also need to be addressed to help people quit? That's a really interesting question. The FDA has funded research examining the impact of lower nicotine cigarettes on smoking behavior and also toxin exposure. We know that women's smoking is less motivated by nicotine and more influenced by what's called
非尼古丁因素的影响，例如感官因素，如外观，和香烟的味道。因此，在由FDA资助的这项工作中，调查女性和男性对这些低尼古丁香烟的反应是否不同将是至关重要的。好的，谢谢。这非常有趣。
non-nicotine factors, such as sensory factors like the site, and the smell of a cigarette. So in this work that's being funded by the FDA, it'll be critical to investigate whether women and men react differently to these lower nicotine cigarettes. Well, thank you. This has been very interesting.
我很感激你来和我们交谈，麦基博士。谢谢你邀请我。有关美国外科医生关于吸烟和健康的报告50周年以及麦基博士工作的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。与美国心理学协会，协会。心理学说话，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子留下评论。
I appreciate you coming and talking with us, Dr. McKee. Thank you for having me. For more information on the 50th anniversary of the US Surgeon General's report on smoking and health and Dr. McKee's work, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Association. Speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
麦基博士，感谢您拔冗与我们交流。谢谢邀请。欲了解美国外科医生总关于吸烟与健康的报告发表50周年的更多信息以及麦基博士的工作，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。